I very clearly remember watching Finnish
TV as this was our only connection to
the free world this is why I from the
bottom of my heart
disliked borders in Europe so allow me
to express here modest enthusiasts when
it comes to grant into institutional
designs in Europe which could lead to a
lesser role of smaller nations in our
common institutions less diversity will
also result in less Europe the key in
decreasing irregular migration is to
work with third countries we must use
all the instruments that our trade visa
and development policies offer new
Africa eel
Alliance proposed by President Juncker
to support job skills and private
investments in Africa
definitely serves long-term effects
Estonia is geographically designed from
Africa but digital world has not
recognized distance in the world of
hybrid war where cybercrime and fake
news security is spite cyberspace should
come by design and Co hand in hand with
emerging technologies we need to build
data integrity into systems to be able
to currenty that the sensors inputs and
computing of the robotic system are not
compromised
it is time to add up proposals to
complete the digital single market and
enable digital transformation the world
will not wait
I really hope
that in ten years from now I can listen
to a colleague from any of the current
candidates come trees in the same row
that I am standing here today a sticky
trionic anton hands and thumbs are
honored it today's Cos Cob
armistice knee say on air OPA holy air
open here arrow pay at Nino's Adamas
modern indeed
as ever Estonia showing the way the
motor for its presidency unity through
balance shows us the way forwards for
our European Union it is time to take it
thank you